I'm a software developer and I'm also in
steinem coin developer and chairman of
an Estonian foundation so initially I I
thought because it's a computer science
related speech to create kind of more
technical presentation but then like
three days ago I invited the two of my
friends who are movie makers or Fred and
Sean they live in LA and to give them a
demo so after the session they just told
me or if you if you deliver this speech
is going to be disaster you know it's
gonna be it's gonna be boring and nobody
wants to you know hear technical stuff
so just tell them like you know insights
into those secretive society is called
coins you know this is what they want to
hear like how you got attached to it and
what's instant him about and and all of
that so einsteinium is not as secretive
actually we try to be very transparent
most of coins are but here we are I
gonna talk about that
so since like missing number like 2009
2009 was a big year for Bitcoin and and
for myself too because in 2009 first
Bitcoin block was my nerd year late
earlier in 2008 Satoshi Nakamoto
released Bitcoin white paper and for me
it was important because I get started
at traffic jam you know I I lived in a
small town of Kenosha in south Wisconsin
and I was doing you know I had a girl
from there he's close so I had a small
consulting business and I would drive it
there to Milwaukee or to Chicago to
visit my clients some of them were
sometimes I I had ability to work you
know remotely from home but often I had
to go there like for
for business meetings and and just to do
coding on inside the firewall so one day
after I finish the work office hours I
took my car and started driving home and
highway was like parking lot you know so
I got stuck at the traffic jam and them
you know when you are in traffic you
turn left and right and you watch people
and those you know cars around small
homes like you can see people eating
pizza or girls putting makeup or iced
even so you know guys shaving so because
they are busy no they are they are
working and they don't have time to they
don't you know they did they are either
busy or commuting and I turn on the
radio and there was a talk show talk
like how economy is going down like how
everything is bad and if it was in some
other place probably it wouldn't catch
my attention but at that time what I was
seeing and what I was hearing just
didn't match like I thought that economy
is just like the some of our all of all
of our activities of if you are if you
all are doing our job like if you are
going to work like how come economy can
be bad and it was clear to me there is
something that I don't understand there
is amazing so I wanted like I feel
emptiness and wanted to Connecticut
myself and just once here on some
questions like where does money come
from have you ever thought about it I
think it's important question like and
and if you start digging you will you
might find your you may open your own
Pandora Box so and I always wanted to
kind of educate myself a little bit more
it was it's not that I did not have good
education I went to some good schools
and all of them but I was I was a bad
student you know I I have hard time to
finish the high school and also
University took me longer and partially
because
I took classes that I really don't like
my parents was were like job security
driven my father was was manager in
being telecom company all my friends
were in Telecom so they thought if I if
we just you know take telecom classes
like it would be easier for me to find a
job but I always loved computer science
and I was if I was not playing games I
was you know with my PC coding since the
age of 14 and you know later on like I
as soon as they finished University I
came to us because I also beside more
education I needed more freedom and
later I figure out that actually those
two things are kinda related like you
get into more freedom by educating
yourself more so but anyway at that time
I just wanted to learn about macro
economy but how I could learn like if I
spent all the time in the either traffic
either commuting or or coding in the
office or just going through tutorials
and all of that so I decided to kind of
take only remote contracts so to free
myself from traffic and have more time
to just study and even go further like I
found a great talent
his name is brother Mozilla which he is
he's actually developer at einsteinium
foundation I'm more like on a business
side now and we can I share the work and
he helped me a lot and I started you
know just reading everything that I was
interested in and this is how I got
introduced to Bitcoin because around
that time block white paper popped up
and I did not jump on the train
immediately it took me quite some time
and because I was scared a little bit
because I learned at that time you know
it was illegal kinda to do some
peer-to-peer stuff you know share
content and I also heard stories that
you know drug cartels are using it
you know to pay across the borders but
actually the money similar to any other
power is it's nothing illegal to have
it's just what you do when you once you
have it but but anyway I got I got
introduced and and after two years of
kind of doing that actually I feel that
I need to do more just by reading stuff
it's not enough because you always read
things to other people view view so I
can decided to just fly back home to
Europe meet with connect with old
friends and just talk to people at the
streets what's going on so I flew there
and I would I travel a lot in Germany in
Switzerland just doing my my research
and then in between flights I had a I
caught a cold friend he is accountant in
London and he just asked me to if we can
have coffee for 30 minutes and then he
came and we met and he told me like I'm
accountant in London and there is a dead
thing Bitcoin you know my clients start
trading it they nobody knows what to do
with it and at the time like I
recognized that okay I I had not enough
knowledge and he told me it's a real
thing you know you can you can sell it
you can buy it you can make money so I
this is the time when I decided to get
to financially engage and kind of you
know put my savings into it because I
was I was saving for like downpayment
and stuff and he also told me there is
that there is a you know great group of
guys in Belgrade they are kinda running
a coin they need some help they need
international experience
so let me troduce to them and that coin
was gain credits so it was established
by a group of
let me put this way like experienced
traders and some juniors developers but
they really lacked like American
corporate experience and this is what I
tried to bring you know to the team and
I started inviting more friends and we
start building community and the whole
markets are picking up and we had
success like we increased the price
maybe thirty times but we had a
different vision where to go next and we
decided to break so I exited and when
you exit the coin is coins are like like
sports club you get emotionally attached
you know I needed some time to after
that like for three months just to to
see what to do next I even tried to
contact other coins I brought emails but
nobody wanted they even didn't bother to
kind of show you know to reply and I
also you know I I knew I knew a lot of a
lot of people in crypto by then I
already met and I met Joe la Sierra who
was kind of Treasury at einsteinium coin
now
einsteinium coin was launched in 2014 it
was launched by literally group of kids
in Canada and what they did they just
launched like ten coins and waited to
see if they get any response from the
market and they really did not have any
skills to to take it to the full
potential so they invited me and
initially I did not want to accept that
responsibility because I didn't know
anything about creep in terms of I was
good trader but I didn't know anything
about programming programming blockchain
because I don't know how it's now
probably have a lot of tutorials online
and
it's different but at that time we just
had like source code and I had to do a
lot of reverse engineering so for the
next six months me and Radha were just
trying to play with the cordon in and to
learn and maybe six months after that
which is beginning of last year we
started delivering some stuff now the
core of the coin was kinda old was
corroded and other coins had my much
better features they we had to build the
infrastructure first like bring nodes to
online and all of that and you can see
like on the graphic above that it was
all flat and then it started picking up
so einsteinium was unique it had pretty
much few unique features and one of the
let's say two important are that one is
one whole feature that I'm going to talk
about just in a bit and the second one
is it's a mining tax because the mission
of einsteinium is to find science we
believe that it's a very important like
I feel said every time I hear the you
know that budgets are cut for NASA and
and and all of that and we introduced
mining tax any time you - than you 2.5%
go to in standing Foundation and I know
before us they were like uh attempts to
can fund few projects since I joined the
open we just open new program I'm
standing one of ours it's going to be
executed during the summer and and back
in said and the winning winner will be
announcing in September but I know in
the past eight
to fund like three projects then just it
just did the value of the coin was and
the market cap was so low so they had
some some success but not not completely
like not what we wanted to do so just
next we had that let me go back to the
Vaughn home feature so beside the text
mining there was an interesting feature
and that feature is is about next
usually you get rewards with each ball
that you mind and once a month during
three hours time frame standing was
programmed to to create three hundred
times more reward than in regular hours
and and that feature was the idea behind
it was kinda to credit lawyer Milloy
among miners but you see when priced are
picking up the abused are picking up
also because what was happening is that
even is its supposed to be random
function because everything is
open-source people could do reverse
engineering and to figure out when it's
happening actually just draw enormous
amount of cash power like right that
moment and just pick the the bounty so
for example if we are about to release
like a million coins per month just
during that period of time you know we
would release like five hundred thousand
and the guys with the most equipment
would take everything so and then it was
okay till we had like one miner but you
know some other guys actually figure out
the same thing and they start competing
and then what was happening is that we
had almost like casino every month we
had enormous cash throwing it at the
network so for example our regular hash
rate would be about 10 gigahertz and it
would go up to 4 Terra caches which is
equal in two big coins like litecoin
like the whole mining world world would
come to understand him every month and
that caused a lot of problems like you
know after they leave the difficulty
level of the network was so high that it
was very difficult to my next block
if there is no blocks to be mined it
means the transactions are stacked so
which means like when I send you coins
you're gonna wait till miner finds the
block to kind of process that
transaction and not only that like we
had a more trouble like - would start
getting more and more creative about
what to do next and for example they
would go even offline and then mine mine
coins and then come back online kind of
try to bypass others because mining is
all about competing for the longest
chain it's a nice tandem is
proof-of-work coin and and basically
what's happening whoever has the the
longest chain it means it has the how to
explain others other others follows
because miners go through loop and they
try to find new block and get money for
for mining but if they if somebody else
finds the block did they listen and they
come and they confirm and if if the
block is right endings
moved to the next block and start mining
the next one so what was happening
during that period of
when when the when guys with the longer
chain come back online all mining blocks
on the online chain get cancelled like
roll back and it means that and we had
situations where even like 800 blocks
were rolled back
what means it means next that if if for
example in in that period of time you
send money to exchange and let's say you
exchange
einsteinium for bitcoins actually you
sold axiom and exchange give you Bitcoin
if transaction go rolls back it means
that the coin never arrived to exchange
from your Windows wallet and what it
means for exchange they give you
bitcoins to give you some money but they
never received an instant so we had to
kind of reimburse them for for for that
period of time and it was really bad
like the exchanges don't like that but
they did support us because einsteinium
stands for good cause for funding
science and so Beatrix and Polonius they
really support us and you can see it
last summer if you take we had to remove
that feature quickly and it was it was
hard task because during the release if
we if we make any error we could cause
that people lose money and exchanges
lose money and we had to be very careful
we did we tried to release for two for
three times first two times we had to
cancel because we did not executed
enough test and and third time when we
roll new released it created enormous
interest
the price of the coin went like 30 times
and in market cap pick to 600 million so
just to go to the next slide in in
today's world groups rise the power and
cryptocurrencies have to have power to
connect people and till we see like in
the past what one scientists like Nikola
Tesla was enough to create a product
today we need like two thousand people
to to put even simple product you know
whatever it is
TV iPhone anything so so till the second
second thing is still till we are
fighting till with boots on the ground
there only our sphere where we are
working together where people easily
find common languages is action it's
science
so it's kind of naturally if you have a
cryptocurrency they have power to
connect people and you have the area of
life where like people do want to work
together on something and easily find
common language and have common goals
and and drives you can see that really
natural that the crypto and in the coin
is good to do some crowdfunding and
especially our tax money mining tax is
not enough to to support project it it's
only little portion so just recently we
introduced the crowdfunding into process
of of supporting projects we are working
on the website supposed to come in
we have along with einsteinium Abarth we
are dedicating a hundred thousand coins
from our fund just to fire to fund like
simple to find something some project
but would be would be good if others
join and let me give you example I since
we published that I got a lot of emails
like every day like we get emails and
this is the interesting project that
they took his example what we are trying
to do it's about the beetus World Health
Organization stated that the beetus is
pandemic that about 30 percent of
population has their BTS and for
diabetes there is no treatment or cure
you can only do maintenance by taking
insulin injecting insulin or taking
pills that stimulate pancreas to produce
insulin and if you want you know there
here and there some medical trials and
medical trials are a kind of processes
where in research hospitals researchers
kind of first form research program if
they want to do and then first they get
approved by by board and then they they
go for money and usually they go to
money and but that organization is
mostly funded by for multikill companies
so if they give money for research they
give under two conditions one is that
you need you need to use immune
suppressed drugs during procedure and
the second is that you have to buy stem
cells like from like certain sources and
those guys from Bahamas they contacted
us and what they do they create so
global cell med is a international
biotech
company that specialized in medical
treatments they have they have business
in Bahamas they want to come in to us
and what's unique about them is they do
treatments just differently
you can go to Bahamas and they in like
for like first and what's different let
me tell you there are two differences
one is they don't use immune suppressed
drugs and the second they use patient's
own stem cells and four is when you if
you want to get treated you can fly
there and then for the first four days
they inject you filgrastim and to boost
stem cells in patients bodies and then
40 they put you on sleep and then they
pick stem cells from from metal bone in
hip bone they don't grow them they they
just return you right away into vein and
what happen is that those team cells
they know they go over the place and
they know how to fix your body and
because Pancras is a kind of place where
you know there be teas needs more they
go to pancreas and and fix and what they
the gut is result is that they have 78
percent positive effect like affected
and fifty percent of their patients did
not even need insulin after that and the
rest just needed much less and then they
did it like some research since like
five years ago and they still have those
patients did not come back I mean you
can repeat the treatment multiple times
but it's it's almost a permanent fix now
they need to come in us and they need
funds they need
- to get approval from Food and Drug
Administration because FDA treats new
protocols as as new medicines and they
need to submit enough data from canal
from local from inside us and they need
money to just contract with hospitals to
start trial if they if they manage to go
through all of this they're gonna be the
only business that kind of treat people
this way and they have also a patent
number so they turned to us they asked
us for like funds and we can help them
so we're gonna run campaign about this
thing so and this is where we come to
the kind of the title of this topic
which is like democratizing research
funding we don't have to wait for
government or institutions to give money
to researchers like we now have tool to
organize ourselves you know anyone can
pick a hundred dollars and donate to to
such a research the good thing is like
the I'm and what is the deal like what
is the difference between kind of what
we do and what let's say other
organizations do it's because we work
with cryptocurrencies and not with Fiat
and cryptocurrencies have market cap
understanding has a market cap of 250
millions it means that as we fund those
projects the value of currencies goes up
so it also means when if you donate
money to some while you're donating
money to other projects you are also
helping this one so everyone benefits
you know and my friends also often ask
me like okay it goes up but you know at
some point goes down so
how to explain that so what I usually
say is that I mean I put like my savings
into it but you don't have to like you
can put I mean not in the project
specifically but into in cryptocurrency
like you deal with a small percentage of
your budget that you can afford to to
lose and it's not that they are
vertically they're working poorly on
cryptocurrency they also have like a
field budget so a tiny portion that we
can all afford actually can make a big
difference on the bigger scale so
recycle funding platform we have we it's
a currency like any other currency so we
we work on many other products and just
recently we released something that we
call Vickers application
the idea behind application is like to
spread that the coins easily around just
to give because it's a in last year it
became really it complicated to to get
into crypto currencies like exchanges it
introduced know your customer procedures
and when I need to explain my friends
how to buy something you know it takes
time so the idea for for this
application is like to easily install on
our phones and then when we exchanged
money mostly is like you know either at
the bars and for gifts for birthdays and
I did not bring other screens but you
can easily pick your friend and you can
send something as a gift like you can
send kids in school can send love or
flowers or and then we are touch coins
to that item so when it arrives they
they get money for for real and then it
also has all kinds of features like for
invoicing customers and
locating locating venues that accept
coin or where they came by coin because
in some other countries they don't have
online banking and they do everything
with cash they buy phones they buy
minutes for phones on some small kills
so the application is made for those
countries to be the guy at the picture
is it's our commercial that we prepared
to lunch and this is how application
looks like we are planning to launch
also marketplace based on einsteinium
coin you can put some items and celica
like a small Amazon and then zero risk
platform it's that's a platform meant
for people they were they don't like to
risk too much that's why we call it a
zero risk it's on the opposite side of
spectrum of margin trading margin
trading increases the rewards but
decreases the risk and with this it's we
build some we're gonna build some
protocols to minimize the risk okay so
if you have any questions like I can I
can answer and then I can continue to
talk about a little bit some other
technical stuff actuation or due to loss
of the currency to being act or lien or
you know the intermediary being no
currency would stay on our kind of
server so we're gonna be kind of
responsible for protecting from from
hacking but many people do average
person does not want me to do trade they
don't
does not want to take a risk so
basically what you want to do is when
you invest money you want to gain a
little bit every year maybe not two
hundred thousand percent like you know
what we had last year maybe maybe a
hundred percent would be enough so there
are there are mechanisms how you can do
that by insuring your dollar amount
basically will be able to come to the
website and then to register and then
put $1,000 into to in to deposit and pay
maybe $50 kinda insurance and then we
guarantee not we but let's say the
partner the insurance partner that'd be
my partner with can guarantee $900 and
we enter into contract let's say for
three months and if three months it
price is lower than you get your AHA
$900 but if it's higher you have
opportunity to kind of lock into next
contract and then again insure $1300 for
$55 and then going to the next step so
something like this we are currency
dollars or you or you we don't because
we don't have money transmission license
but we are talking to businesses they do
have and thinking about launching
product like this it's on it's on the
roadmap it's not in production but we
are kind of just building concepts
around it I can cover I can go through
basic blockchain concepts and explain
how how it how it how does it work yes
so the very the the core element is in
every blockchain is that ledger fide
basically it's a it's a date it's a data
structure it's a list of transactions
what we do we we keep we pack those
transactions into some frames those
frames we call blocks so transactions
are packed for Bitcoin in each ten
minutes into blocks and on on understand
um it's one minute so we are in that
regard like faster currency once they
are packed and committed to the ledger
it's really hard to go back and to
change transactions and in order to do
this and it is because we have a big
computing power behind it to ensure that
transactions are valid so the second
concept of blockchain is peer-to-peer
network so those wallets that kind of
maintain that ledger file they are all
connected to each other maybe not to all
to each other like each each node is
connected like to 100 other nodes and
they all have the copy of Ledger's
that's why we call it distributed ledger
because it does not sit on one place but
on many many places and third concept of
blockchain is transparency
what transparency means that we can see
on blockchain amounts but we we don't
see who is behind behind those amounts
the this is also where
privacy and pseudonymity comes into the
picture in real world we you cannot
always choose your business partners you
can choose your friends but business
partners you you don't choose in
sometimes you have to worked with people
that you don't know so that's why we use
a third party and middleman's that we
trust and those third parties are banks
and accountants and governments and not
reason or cash just simple cash so now I
don't want to say that blockchain has
power to replace them but kinda to
minimize the fact now we can we have
mechanism in place where we can send
money directly to each other and there
is also a mechanism where we can check
everything we can check all balances and
those principles like even though
bitcoin was released in 2009 those
principles were known even before 2000
and even earlier but was what was
missing was the computing power and just
recently we got powerful computers and
the network is very secure you ask about
hacking and you can hear the stories
about that exchange going down or this
exchange got hack those exchanges are
banks that kept a wallet open the
underlying Bitcoin protocol is very
secured it's never been hacked and why
so secure is it because currently be
because there is a huge computing power
behind it the whole Bitcoin network kind
of spends 45 thereabout hours and it's
enough to power like five million homes
in u.s. or the whole country in New
Zealand
many people complain about that
and that's why they try to kind of
figure out new methods and mechanisms
like if we can do it you know cheaper
and I have slide it talks about other
consensus mechanisms like proof of proof
of stakes that can spend much less power
but I have to ask you one question if we
kind of take out all those middlemen see
if you don't have to if you don't have
to pay lawyers and and courts and you
know people with guns to insure our
business and transactions then they have
to pay something and what we are paying
is the electricity so I think it's still
cheaper to pay electricity then you know
people with guns and you know I kind of
touched it the irreversibility which
means there is a power that kind of
ensures that it's really it it's not
easy to kind of cheat the system and
corrupt transaction and you know do
something so there is power in place and
then there is also program ability as a
concept which means you can program
currency you can build your business
logic into blockchain you can you can
and I'm trying to remember remember
maybe some good example but but
currencies are just one application of
blockchain you know those are all
blockchain principles which means that
you can use blockchain in for some other
stuff for example for voting for public
accounting those pieces of those current
those elements can represent anything
else it can represent kilowatt hours and
then you can you can build your
applications on top of blockchain they
can be triggered by by events into the
wallet so as soon as you receive payment
then you can do something else and you
can even roll your logic like on
from your application into blockchain so
all principles that we use in
programming anyway and just to go for
the further so I want to have cover
hashing and then to show you how blocks
look like and then transactions mining
and what Forks are so I know do you have
any questions so I can go further with
this so what's going on when I when I
send coins to from my wallet to to your
wallet for example my wallet the
defiance transaction and then submits
transaction to - - - - constantly - to
two things one they constantly listen
like if the receiving transactions and
the invalidating if if transactions are
ok and then they are trying to put
enough enough power to solve the
mathematical equation and if they solve
equation they broadcast to all other
miners that they have result so the
result is accepted the miner gets
credited and then they move to the next
and how they do in in in our experience
it looks like we are sending coins from
so I'm talking about transactions I just
don't go by the order because
transaction is the most important thing
so we have impression that coins go from
wallet - wallet but what's actually
happening is that transactions go from
the coins go from transaction to the
transaction so in order for for me to
send 10,000 coins to someone I need to
kind of prove that I received those
coins and then if you see that for
example transactions six transaction
four and six
transaction for received 20 coins from
previous transaction we use mechanisms
of public and private keys to do that
we need to sign incoming transactions
and then design out coming transactions
and this is how we confirmed that those
those are like those are the owners
money a private key and public key do
you know we use them like everywhere we
use them for example when we store
passwords and no I I get confused sorry
so it's like we use caching for for
storing passwords vu we create public
key based on private keys and public
keys we can send to everyone else but
private key we keep for ourselves
because stuff that we are receiving
other people are packing and encrypting
content with the public key and they
send they sent to to us and then we are
decrypting with private key so if
someone gets into possession of your
private key they can they can have your
money so it's important to keep your
private key backup and secure so once
once the type of transaction come come
to miner miners because they get
multiple transaction they do they hatch
them and hashing is this thing here so
caching is a one-way function it's a
function to encrypt stuff so it for in
hashing output has the same length
regardless of what we give like input so
it all and this is this picture is used
it's good
checking the big amount of data because
if something changes and to output we
can easily spot if if output is change
and this is one wave function so it's a
it's very easy to go from input it's go
very easy to go forward it's very easy
to check output based on the input but
if you if you go other way around is
very difficult that's wise oh and then
and then being when we hash transactions
we actually hash each transaction and
then the hash hashes and then we pack
everything into one thing and in print
it'll block so block has gonna header
and it has that body the body is just
the hash of all hashes we call it
Merkley Road and then the header has
also some other hashes it has previous
block cache it has some other flags as
we're processing those transactions we
are adding latest latest one to the top
of the chain and the next thing I want
to to cover in terms of those concepts
is forking so I talked earlier about
about orphan blocks and sometimes it
happens that a to of miners find us a
block at the same time and how diff and
if they find block the if the if - -
find block at the same time one block is
usually accepted by the rest of the
network and the other is is rejected
those are rejected blocks are we call
them orphans and beside those those are
kind of occasional Forks but beside that
we have hard Forks and we have source
forks forks basically means new releases
if we every time we want to improve
something in the blockchain we release
new version and then
rulz start from certain block number and
then it means that everyone in the
system has to kind of switch to to
update otherwise they will be on the
wrong on the wrong chain and isolated
like they would not be able to send
transactions to two exchanges or two
friends I want to talk a little bit
about blockchain types we have the
currency that we know are usually public
chains public means that anyone can
download the chain and kind of do audit
and and go through the through the
balances but they are like you can make
them also private you can release the
chain and give voltage just to certain
people and usually banks or banks or
bigger organizations they like you know
they use private chain so then we have
changed like based on proof of work or
proof of stake we talked about I just
started talking I talked a little bit
about proof of stake basically proof of
work means that you get new coins based
on computing power you need you need
better equipment and for for proof you
get new coins if your miner based on the
computing power that you have so people
tend to buy stronger machines to do the
mining proof of stake you get coins
based on proof of stake is different if
you the biggest criticism for proof of
work is that it spends a lot of energy
so they figure out that instead of
because everyone is competing to find a
new block they spend like all the energy
and people figure
let's say let's not let everyone compete
less delegate about not in the network
that's going to be chosen to validate
blocks and transactions and instead of
instead of everyone trying to do if you
need more computing power you add more
processor and this is how you get
computing power and I know really how to
explain this is kind of its against some
crypto philosophy because if people tend
to get together to create more power and
this is how we get into something that
we call mining pools and this is also
dangerous because if mining pools if big
mining pools get together they can have
a majority in the interval ting so when
they if they can also start approving
like fragile transactions so what huh
yeah so in order to to kind of limit
that became batavia to kind of feature
memory access memory access has each
memory has been bit and you have to wait
on memory to get a result it's not easy
to scale when you when you try to add
more memories you still wait on that
response time and this is something that
can be used in mining so many coins kind
of use that that features that kind of
prevents people from getting together
creating mining pools and and kind of
taking advantage of the of the big cash
power we have
I listed here like coins that they use
compute intensive algorithms those are
like and first algorithm that came out
was sha-256
it was released by in NSA make may was
made available for the public but but
its first very quickly after that a
Sigma Sheen came out and so then people
moved to the next which was the script
script for algorithm was for quite some
time very popular that's why I paid I I
saw maybe five hundred coins on the list
using script algorithm including
einsteinium litecoin and others but
script algorithm also got infected by by
a six and then on the other side we have
those memory bound algorithms don't
for example if theorem at the cache is
using it and then a bunch of privacy
coins like like kryptonite Manero
another so it's very difficult to create
a sixth for memory bound machines
these are all slightly different type of
algorithms if I'm trying to I don't know
anything about this but I'm trying to
pass a Selectric or anything I have my
choice of algorithm sir I have to use
the algorithm that comes oh no no you
don't use as a minded like algorithm
it's uh it's the coin developers they
define the algorithm and then coin is
released you don't know the source code
and you try mining there is also
separation on coins versus tokens just
lately tokens became very popular tokens
are just representation of off any asset
we can we are talking about tokenizing
economy now because we live in a limited
world and then we can tokenize any asset
usually tokens they are used to
represent stocks in the company that's
why our like legislation is after them
it's very easy to create a token you
don't need your own chain you just need
to follow the template and and really
analyse the token in that that regard
you have less flexibility what you can
do with it if you want to release your
own coin you have to kind of dig deeper
to currency with no privacy guarantees
would simplify the algorithms it's a
good question and this is actually what
I was going to say next and this is
since for the first time I'm going to
announce that at our organization we
made the decision and
actually start taking steps to build
some mechanisms and features inside our
coin that will actually pop arise and
actually feature transparency because
they think it's important on and this is
I said like there are like multiple
unique things about einsteinium this one
will also bring us uniqueness because
most of the coins will be on other side
of the spectrum and I'm pretty sure that
we're going to face some criticism about
that because it's kind of antique crypto
because you know people in crypto like
privacy and pseudonymity and but it's
okay like there are plenty of coins that
they kind of force that we want to until
privacy and pseudonymity czar essential
to satisfy like to to protect our basic
freedoms especially when we do when we
exchange volume value I think
transparency another spectrum is very
important because it brings it it can
help to bring corruption down and
especially with what we are trying to do
with einsteinium we can we want to bring
corruption down and increase the trust
in areas where we need the most which
are called because which are
crowdfunding
philanthropy charity even politics so
we're going to work on that we're going
to build features and very CLE quickly
maybe within four to six months release
chained it's going to be leading into
that area actually will be only one but
you know if other coins joined and will
be leading toward that direction because
I think
you know there are many questions asked
about future of the currency and you can
see some even you know big figure or big
figures like stating different things
about crypto but I think no one
questions blockchain and I think what we
try to do we can with transparency we
can definitely create more fair and an
honest world just to give you what we
are trying to do is just to give you one
one fact like according to giving USA
Americans Americans alone donated three
hundred ninety billions in 2017 last
year so with the market cap where we are
which is like seventy million dollars I
think it brings tremendous opportunity
for understand IAM to serve such
industry so you know i would i would i
would invite you to join you can join
and join us we are open you don't have
to work full-time you can dedicate as as
little as one hour a week or a month or
something but you can join our core team
or you can join in promoting and anybody
want here is my contact info